welcome back to Modern Agri machines
today we're diving into the fascinating
world of asparagus a vegetable
celebrated for its distinct taste and
incredible nutritional value join us as
we explore its Origins the regions where
it's grown its economic impact and the
rigorous and the rigorous yet rewarding
process that brings asparagus from the
farm to our tables asparagus is one of
the oldest cultivated vegetables with
Origins tracing back to over 2,000 years
ago in the Mediterranean regions of
Europe Northern Africa and parts of Asia
it's even referenced in ancient Egyptian
text prized by the Romans and was widely
grown in Europe by the 16th century
today this perennial vegetable is grown
and enjoyed across the globe today some
of the largest asparagus producing
regions are in the United States Peru
China Germany and Spain in the US
California Washington and Michigan are
the top producers globally the asparagus
industry is valued at over $20 billion
reflecting its importance to farmers
exporters and food Industries this crop
brings immense value especially to rural
communities creating jobs and providing
a steady
income asparagus is a nutrient-dense
vegetable rich in vitamins and minerals
known for its numerous health health
benefits it contains high levels of
vitamins a c e k and is especially rich
in folic acid essential for cell health
and vital for fetal development
asparagus is also high in fiber which
AIDS digestion and prevents constipation
this vegetable is a powerful source of
antioxidants which help protect cells
from damage caused by free radicals
reducing the risk of chronic diseases
minerals like potassium and asparagus
help regulate blood pressure and support
heart health another highlight is its
low calorie content and lack of
cholesterol making it ideal for those
looking to maintain weight or improve
their diet with a low glycemic index
asparagus is a safe choice for those
managing diabetes not only does it
provide nutritional benefits but it also
boosts immunity and contributes to
overall health when regularly
incorporated into a balanced
diet preparing the soil making Ray beds
implanting asparagus are essential steps
to ensure the plants grow strong and
productive asparagus thrives in well-
draining loose soil rich in nutrients
with a pH of 6.5 to 7.5 preferring a
slightly alkaline environment before
planting Farmers should till the soil to
a depth of 30 40 C DS and add decomposed
organic matter to improve fertility
creating raised beds is also crucial
these beds should be 20 30 cm high and 1
1 .5 M wide to prevent root water
logging and improve drainage during
heavy rains between each bed a drainage
channel of 30 40 cm should be
established to prevent water
accumulation there are two common ways
to plant asparagus using roots and using
seedlings when planting Roots Farmers
dig holes 105 CM deep on the beds place
the asparagus Roots inside cover lightly
with Soil and Water gently to keep the
soil moist
currently many farms have adopted
machinery for planting asparagus by root
to increase labor productivity in
economic efficiency for seed planting
seeds are first germinated in Nursery
trays with loose potting soil after 8 10
weeks when the seedlings reach 10 to 15
cm in height and have two turn to three
leaves they can be transplanted into the
beds in both cases the soil should be
kept consistently moist but not water
logged to support stable asparagus
[Music]
growth Harvest ing asparagus is a
meticulous process as the quality of
asparagus significantly impacts its
market value although there are machines
available to Aid in this task most
asparagus harvesting is still done by
hand particularly on small and
medium-sized Farms manual harvesting
Remains the most common method due to
its flexibility and precision Farmers
typically harvest in the early morning
or late afternoon when cooler
temperatures help maintain the asparagus
is freshness they select Spears that
reach about 20 25 cm in heat with an
appropriate thickness cutting close to
the base to avoid damaging the plant and
allowing it to keep growing manual
harvesting enables workers to carefully
observe and select only the spears that
meet quality standards
[Music]
mechanical harvesting is used on some
large scale Farms or when extensive
harvesting is required especially if
labor resources are limited asparagus
Harvesters are designed with cutting and
collection mechanisms that allow them to
move along the rows trimming the spears
at a set height and collecting them in a
storage bin however mechanical
Harvesters often struggle to match the
consistency and accuracy of hand
harvesting machines lack the flexibility
to select only the best quality Spears
which can impact the final product
[Music]
in conclusion while technology is
advancing hand harvesting Remains the
preferred method for asparagus
especially where quality and uniformity
are priorities
[Music]
after harvesting asparagus undergos a
careful process to ensure that it
reaches the market in the best possible
condition freshly harvested asparagus is
first taken to a processing area where
it's thoroughly washed to remove any
soil pesticides and other residues
typically this process involves soaking
and spraying the asparagus with clean
cool water once clean the asparagus is
sorted by size color and quality grading
machines or in some cases skilled
workers assess the asparagus based on
criteria such as thickness length and
the absence of blemishes spear tips that
are tightly closed vibrant in color and
of uniform thickness are typically
graded as premium While others are
designated for secondary markets sorting
is important not only for appearance but
also for pricing and to meet specific
customer demands after grading the
asparagus is carefully packed into
suitable containers typically in bunches
tied with rubber band or placed in trays
packaging often includes moisture
retaining pads to maintain freshness
during transit in some cases asparagus
is packed in modified atmosphere
packaging to prolong shelf life the
packaging design including clear
labeling and sometimes even branding
helps attract buyers while providing
necessary information about the product
overall these steps ensure that the
asparagus arrives at its destination
fresh appealing and ready for consumers
the attention to detail in each part of
the process helps maintain the quality
ensuring that consumers receive a
product that's both delicious and
Visually
appealing thank you for watching our
video on the modern Agri machines
Channel we hope this video has given you
a clearer understanding of the process
of growing harvesting and packaging
asparagus don't forget to hit like And
subscribe so you won't miss other
exciting content on Modern agriculture
see you in our next videos